hey guys dr. Burke here I had a lot of
requests for honey okay raw honey versus
pasteurized honey so let's just talk
about it it takes 60,000 bees 55,000
miles to make one pound of honey and
then we steal their honey okay we give
them sugar water it's just terrible but
honey in the right form is very
antimicrobial anti-inflammatory and
especially if you mix it with a little
apple cider vinegar and lemon and water
you know it can help you anti-allergy
why because it has pollen and has other
factors that really will help build up
your immune system and even can lower
blood pressure and it has B vitamins
magnesium calcium potassium says
basically it's a sweetener that has a
lot of good stuff however it still has
50% fructose in 50% glucose which means
it can flow down your weight loss and it
does have a relatively high glycemic
index now there are certain types of
honey especially with Tupelo honey that
is much lower and it's used for
diabetics and small small amounts so if
you want to consume honey for certain
health reasons
the diversion that I would consume would
be the manuka honey okay find that
because because it's a really
unprocessed raw honey that has a lot of
great properties but here's the thing
make sure your honey is always raw and
it's not pasteurized why because when
they pasteurizer they cook it to destroy
everything it so now you're just getting
pure sugar now yes it's true that if
here you're not going to give raw honey
to a baby because there's a risk of
getting botulism and by the way my son
when you were six months old got
botulism not from honey from some other
source but it can be very very scary and
dangerous so you don't want to give
small infants but if you're adult you
can get away with it very easily but so
my overall impression honey is that it's
really the quality make sure it's raw
and and go ahead and have some if you're
trying to improve your allergies or your
immune system and you want to do the
Sunnah like a peer
attic spaces all right thanks for
watching